wir befinden uns mitten
im Anfang der Grippesaison.
Die geht etwa von Oktober bis März.
Wer schon mal eine richtige Grippe
hatte, weiß, das ist nicht schön,
aber muss man sich
wirklich dagegen impfen lassen?
Im Gegensatz zu anderen Impfungen,
wie z.B. gegen Masern,
Diphtherie, Tetanus,
wird die Grippeimpfung nicht
allgemein offiziell empfohlen.
Heißt: Sie wird nicht
von der STIKO empfohlen,
von der Ständigen Impfkommission,
die die Expertengrundlage liefert
für öffentliche Impf-Empfehlungen.
Aber was bedeutet so
eine STIKO-Empfehlung überhaupt?
Wie gefährlich ist die Grippe,
wie gefährlich ist die Impfung?
Solltest du dich diese Saison noch
impfen lassen? Das klären wir jetzt.
* Titelmelodie *
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2019)
Fangen wir mit dem Wort Grippe an.
Die Grippe oder Influenza
wird oft mit einer Erkältung
in einen Topf geworfen.
Schließlich wird eine Erkältung
auch als Grippaler Infekt bezeichnet.
Durch diese namentliche Ähnlichkeit
wird eine Grippe oft als Erkältung
missverstanden und unterschätzt.
Es gibt zwar ähnliche Symptome,
wie Husten, Schnupfen,
Kopf- und Gliederschmerzen,
aber die Grippe
ist eine ganz andere Liga.
Während eine Erkältung
meist ohne Fieber und
mit nur schwachem Fieber daherkommt,
haut die Grippe einen
mit sehr starkem Fieber um.
Auch der Verlauf ist anders:
Eine Erkältung fängt meist
mit einem kleinen Halskratzen an,
die Symptome werden
die nächsten 2-3 Tage schlimmer,
ebben aber wieder ab.
Eine Grippe überfährt
einen so richtig von Anfang an
und kann im Krankenhaus oder, im
schlimmsten Fall, gar tödlich enden.
Die Grippesaison 2017/18
war die stärkste und tödlichste
seit 30 Jahren:
Alleine in Deutschland
starben 25.000 Menschen.
Die Zahl der Todesfälle
für 2018/19 liegt noch nicht vor,
aber das Robert-Koch-Institut spricht
von einer moderaten Grippesaison.
Die Grippe ist also von Jahr zu Jahr
verschieden gefährlich.
Woran liegt das?
Es gibt leider
nicht nur ein Grippevirus,
sondern
eine ganze Influencer-Familie,
also Influenza-Familie.
Es gibt verschiedene
Grippeviren-Typen.
Die Typen A und B
sind die relevanten für uns.
Die sorgen jedes Jahr
für die saisonale Grippe.
Von diesen Typen gibt es aber auch
noch Untertypen, also Subtypen.
Die Subtypen des Typ A z.B. werden
nach der HN-Bezeichnung benannt.
Namen wie H1N1 oder H3N2 habt ihr
vielleicht schon mal gehört.
H und N beziehen sich dabei auf
die genaue Zusammensetzung der Viren
bzw. auf die genaue
Zusammensetzung ihrer Oberfläche.
Die Grippeviren könnt ihr euch
vorstellen wie gemeine Kugeln,
deren Oberflächen
mit kleinen Spikes versehen sind.
Jeder der Stacheln
besteht aus Proteinen,
mit deren Hilfe die Viren
in unsere Zellen eindringen
und sich darin vermehren.
H und N stehen jetzt für
2 verschiedene Oberflächenproteine:
Hämagglutinin und Neuraminidase.
Von H und N gibt es
aber verschiedene Formen.
Und je nachdem,
welche Form auf der jeweiligen
Virusoberfläche zu finden ist,
bekommt das Virus
eine entsprechende Bezeichnung.
Es gibt also verschiedene Virustypen,
die unterteilt werden in Subtypen,
die werden noch mal
unterteilt in Stämme.
Es ist also eine Großfamilie.
Und diese Familie hat es in sich.
Die Grippe
ist eine Infektionskrankheit,
die prinzipiell
durch Impfungen bekämpft werden kann.
Die Oberflächenproteine
sind auch "Antigene".
D.h. in diesem Fall: Sie sind
Angriffspunkt für unser Immunsystem.
Unser Immunsystem kann nämlich
passend zu diesen Virus-Antigenen
Antikörper bilden.
Übersteht man die Krankheit, kann
das Immunsystem dank der Antikörper
beim nächsten Virusangriff schnell
reagieren und den Erreger zerstören.
Wie bei anderen Impfungen
kann man auch bei der Grippeimpfung
den Körper
auf so einen Angriff vorbereiten,
ohne dass man die echte Krankheit
durch- und überstehen muss.
Bei einer Grippeimpfung verabreicht
man z.B. abgeschwächte Virenversionen
oder auch nur Virenteile.
Die können die Grippe
zwar nicht auslösen,
enthalten aber trotzdem die Antigene,
sodass unser Immunsystem
die passenden Antikörper bilden kann.
Durch dieses "Immunsystem-Training"
kann es zu typischen
Impf-Nebenwirkungen kommen,
wie z.B. Rötungen der Einstichstelle,
Abgeschlagenheit, leichtes Fieber.
Doch diese Beschwerden
vergehen nach ein paar Tagen.
Der Körper ist dann gewappnet,
wenn der echte,
gefährliche Erreger angreift.
Nur, welcher ist der
echte Erreger unter diesen vieren?
Bzw.: Welches ist
der richtige Impfstoff?
Bei anderen Krankheiten
muss man sich 1-2 Mal impfen lassen,
vielleicht ist noch
mal eine Auffrischungsimpfung dabei,
aber man hat lebenslangen Schutz.
Bei der Grippe ist es anders,
da muss man sich
jede Saison neu impfen lassen.
Die saisonale Grippe
wird von Grippeviren
des Typs A und B verursacht.
Das kann man
noch weiter konkretisieren:
Es gibt 4 verschiedene
Grippevirengruppen,
von denen verschiedene Variationen
weltweit ihr Unwesen treiben.
Es ist ein Riesenact.
Auf der ganzen Welt gibt es Labore,
die lassen sich Patientenproben
zuschicken und untersuchen,
welche konkreten Grippeviren
gerade umhergehen.
In Deutschland gibt es das Nationale
Referenzzentrum für Influenza.
All die internationalen Labore
übermitteln ihre Daten
an die Weltgesundheitsorganisation.
Die sagt jede Grippesaison an:
Passt auf,
liebe Impfstoff-Entwickler,
die aktuellen Impfstoffe müssen die
Antigene folgender Viren enthalten.
Das ist nicht so einfach,
denn so ein Impfstoff
muss erst mal hergestellt werden.
Für uns, für die Nordhalbkugel,
wird schon im Februar
schätzend vorausgesagt,
welche Grippeviren in der kommenden
Saison im Umlauf sein werden,
damit man noch bis Herbst
genügend Zeit hat,
um ausreichend Impfstoff
herzustellen.
Deswegen kommt es durchaus vor,
dass der Impfstoff nicht genau
zu den tatsächlichen Viren passt.
Das ist leider noch nicht alles.
Grippeviren sind
sehr wandlungsfähige Viren.
Es gibt dabei 2 Wandlungsmechanismen:
Wenn Grippeviren sich vermehren,
also bei ihrer Reproduktion,
kommt es immer wieder
zu kleinen genetischen Veränderungen,
Kopierfehlerchen.
Die führen dazu, dass
die Oberflächenproteine der Viren,
also die Antigene
sich leicht verändern.
Sind die Veränderungen klein genug,
können die Antikörper
unseres Immunsystems
die Viren immer noch erkennen.
Aber die Antigen-Drifts
können sich mit der Zeit anhäufen,
bis die Veränderungen so groß sind,
dass unser Immunsystem
das Virus nicht mehr erkennt.
Auch deswegen muss man jedes Jahr
die Viren neu bestimmen,
die Impfstoffe anpassen.
Der 2.Mechanismus
ist der Antigen-Shift.
Der ist richtig scarry.
Bei einem Shift
kombinieren sich genetische
Eigenschaften verschiedener Viren,
wobei eine so wesentliche und abrupte
genetische Veränderung auftritt,
dass ein ganz neues Virus entsteht.
Solche neuen Viren
können extrem gefährlich sein,
weil unser Immunsystem das nicht
kennt, nichts damit anfangen kann
und wir sehr anfällig sind
für diese Viren.
Sowas kann passieren, wenn Viren,
die normalerweise Tiere befallen,
z.B. Vögel oder Schweine,
die Fähigkeit gewinnen
Menschen zu infizieren.
Beispiel: 2006 machte
die Vogelgrippe Schlagzeilen,
weil ein H5N1-Virus, das eigentlich
nur für Vögel gefährlich war,
doch Menschen infizierte.
Das Virus war für Menschen
zum Glück generell wenig ansteckend.
Also weltweit infizierten sich
weniger als 900 Menschen.
Aber mehr als die Hälfte
dieser Menschen verstarb.
Also das Virus war extrem tödlich.
2009 gab es dann Panik wegen
der Mexikanischen Schweinegrippe.
Diese Schweinegrippe
war hoch ansteckend.
Weltweit infizierten sich
rund 200 Mio.Menschen, eine Pandemie.
Doch wir hatten Glück.
Das hoch ansteckende Virus
führte nicht zu einem Massensterben
wie etwa bei der Spanischen Grippe,
die 20-50 Mio.Menschenleben forderte.
Es starben an der Schweinegrippe
weltweit weniger als 20.000 Menschen,
also nur ein Bruchteil
der 200 Mio.Infizierten.
Aber: Das Schweinegrippe-Virus
bleibt eine drohende Gefahr,
weil es sich auch
in Vögeln aufhalten kann.
Und wir wollen uns nicht ausmalen,
was passiert,
wenn da ein Virus entstehen sollte,
dass so ansteckend ist
wie die Schweinegrippe,
aber so tödlich wie die Vogelgrippe.
Noch mal: Virenveränderungen,
die durch antigenen Drift entstehen,
passieren graduell.
Man kann das beobachten
und durch die Entwicklung von
Impfstoffen entsprechend reagieren.
Bei plötzlichen Veränderungen
durch antigenen Shift
können wir nur hoffen, dass die
ExpertInnen es rechtzeitig schaffen,
ein Gegenmittel rauszuhauen.
Oder wir können nur beten, dass es so
glimpflich ausgeht wie letztes Mal.
Kommen wir zurück zum täglichen
Geschäft, bzw. zum jährlichen.
Die wichtige Frage ist:
Wir wissen, dass Grippeviren
ein bisschen arschiger sind
als manch andere Viren,
weil es so viele davon gibt,
weil sie sich ständig verändern.
Man kann mit den Impfstoffen
die tatsächlichen
Grippeviren knapp verfehlen.
Bedeutet: Selbst wenn ich
gegen Grippe geimpft bin,
kann ich immer
noch eine Grippe bekommen.
Es gibt auch
bei den klassischen Impfungen Fälle,
wo zum Beispiel Menschen
Antikörper gegen bestimmte Erreger
nicht ausbilden
und so dann keinen Impfstoff haben,
aber das ist selten.
Runtergebrochen kann man sagen:
Die klassischen Impfungen, die auch
von der STIKO empfohlen werden,
bieten einen sicheren Schutz,
die Grippeimpfung nicht.
Allerdings ist eine Grippeimpfung,
die leicht daneben ist,
oft besser als gar keine.
D.h.: Man kann sich
trotzdem anstecken,
aber dafür leidet man kürzer unter
der Grippe, die Symptome sind milder,
man landet weniger oft im
Krankenhaus, senkt das Sterberisiko.
Ich habe mich dieses Jahr
gegen Grippe impfen lassen,
weil ich als Schwangere
zu den Risikogruppen gehöre,
für die die STIKO
die Grippeimpfung empfiehlt.
Dazu zählen u.a.
auch ältere Menschen über 60 Jahre,
Menschen mit chronischen Krankheiten
wie z.B. Diabetes
oder mit chronischen
Atemwegserkrankungen wie Asthma.
Für uns kann eine Grippe
deutlich stärker ausfallen
und deutlich gefährlicher ausgehen.
Werdende Mütter geben ihre Antikörper
übrigens auch über die Plazenta
an das Baby weiter.
Das wird somit auch geschützt.
Die Grippeschutzimpfung wird auch
für einige Berufsgruppen empfohlen,
z.B. für medizinisches Personal,
um sich selbst,
aber auch die Patienten zu schützen.
2018 ließ ich mich auch impfen,
im Rahmen einer Quarks-Reportage
über die Grippeimpfung.
Da ich letzten Winter
echt viel Arbeit hatte,
evtl. erinnert ihr euch an mein
Burn-out-Video, kam mir das gelegen.
So konnte ich das Risiko reduzieren,
durch eine Grippe auszufallen.
Aber für mich als gesunde,
erwachsene Frau ist
die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch,
eine Grippe problemlos zu überstehen.
Deswegen gab es für mich 2018 keinen
besonderen medizinischen Bedarf.
Deswegen empfiehlt die STIKO
auch für gesunde Erwachsene
die Grippeimpfung nicht.
Aber ich wusste auch,
dass ich mir mit einer Grippeimpfung
nichts Schlimmes antue.
Entgegen mancher Gerüchte
kann man durch eine Grippeimpfung
keine Grippe bekommen.
Die Teile der Viren, so wie sie bei
der Grippeimpfung gespritzt werden,
sind dazu nicht in der Lage.
Dieses Missverständnis
kann aber entstehen,
wenn man nach einer Grippeimpfung
eine normale Erkältung bekommt,
gegen die man ja nicht geimpft ist,
die man aber
mit einer Grippe verwechselt.
Oder, das kann auch passieren:
Wenn man sich kurz vor oder nach
der Impfung mit der Grippe ansteckt,
kommt die Impfung quasi zu spät,
weil es 1-2 Wochen dauert,
bis der Impfschutz aufgebaut ist.
Deswegen ist es wichtig zu verstehen,
nur weil die STIKO
eine Impfung nicht empfiehlt,
heißt es nicht, dass sie davon abrät.
Das betont das Robert-Koch-Institut
hier noch mal ausdrücklich.
Wie bei allen Impfungen gilt:
Impfung ist immer auch
ein Schutz unserer Mitmenschen.
Wenn ihr jemanden in der Familie
habt, der gefährdet ist,
aber aus irgendeinem Grund
nicht geimpft werden kann,
könnt ihr durch eure Impfung
Schutz bieten.
Noch mal: Die Grippeimpfung
kann vor Grippe schützen,
ist aber weniger effizient
als andere Impfungen,
weil Grippeviren Arschlöcher sind.
Die Grippeimpfung
muss jedes Jahr neu gemacht werden,
weil Grippeviren Arschlöcher.
Selbst wenn man sich,
trotz Impfung, ansteckt,
können die Symptome
deutlich milder ausfallen.
Menschen mit erhöhtem Risiko
sollten sich unbedingt
jedes Jahr impfen lassen.
Denn die Grippe
ist eine ernstzunehmende Krankheit,
die tödlich sein kann.
Menschen außerhalb der Risikogruppen
müssen sich nicht impfen lassen.
Sie können sich
aber dazu entscheiden,
wenn sie andere schützen wollen oder
keinen Bock auf eine Grippe haben.
Die meisten maiLab-Zuschauer
gehören nicht zu einer Risikogruppe,
aber wollt ihr euch
trotzdem impfen lassen,
könnt ihr euch erkundigen,
ob die Krankenkasse das bezahlt
oder euer Arbeitgeber.
Immer mehr Arbeitgeber machen das,
weil sie kein Interesse
an eurem Ausfall haben.
Teilt das Video
gerne mit euren Eltern,
wenn die schon 60 sein sollten,
Großeltern, schwangeren Freunden usw.
Ansonsten:
Kommt gut durch den Winter,
bzw. wir sehen uns ja wieder nächste
Woche. Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.